واحد مختلف هو أيضا عالمي
الحليب أو اللعب الافتراضي van der people
إنه يرقص لفترة أطول
ليس من الجيد أن تكون الحقيقة قادرة على القيام به
الرياضة في الهواء الطلق أيام كثيرة في
الحبس جيد جدا ونحن
سعيد جدا لوجودي
مالك البحر العام الذي هو نهرك
تجاهل المزيد من الكومة وابنة
إيمانك الشخصي
تلفزيون الهاتف الذكي هذا متحرك
أيضا أن في أفضل وضعها
الحياة إذا وضع العامل لحظة
مشدود إلى tvn نفس هاتا من أنيمي
في حياتك المهنية نتج عن الحلفاء
سوف نكون قد تغيرنا للقفز من أجل أمريكا
الطريق والعالم أو أي شيء
نعم جيدا مربكة بعض الشيء لأنني كنت
فهمت ذلك حتى الساعة 8 مساءً
يمكنك القدوم إلى الشاطئ
بهدوء أراها وصلت هنا هناك
قلة من الناس وكان هناك سوء فهم
كان مجرد نزهة إذا كانت المعلومات مفقودة
لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أن هناك مرونة
من قبل الشرطة
إيجابية ولذا فنحن على مسافة
نحن مع الأشخاص الذين نعيش معهم
لا يوجد
هذا العام جالسًا يأخذ المنطقة
بعد المباراة ما تطلبه الأمر
وظيفة من أكثر مناطق جيمينيز الشرق تنوعًا
أعطاه برشلونة الخاص بك
هذه القطرات هي التي اضطررنا إليها
اجعلوا من الصحة